[Music]
major school districts around the
country are searching for new
superintendents in the process everyone
is looking for an innovative someone
with new and exciting ideas but along
the way a simple truth is too often lost
we forget that success in any
organization is mostly a matter of
precision discipline and focus exciting
ideas are only as good as their
execution too often in the search for
innovation districts swing back and
forth between new programs and don't do
any of them especially well teachers and
students get swamped by a tide of
ceaseless half-serious change some
district is inevitably embracing reform
a and rejecting reform B as misguided
just as another is latching on to be as
shiny and new and discarding reform a is
old and tired here's a suggestion
don't ask whose innovative and don't
look for a change agent there's nothing
wrong with any event but it's a
distraction what matters much more than
what leaders promise to do for kids is
how they are going to do it what do you
think districts should look for in a
superintendent let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI